bonjour eric zemmour bonjour vous
revenez sur les cinq ans de la
république en marche et vous méditer sur
les échecs aux élections locales du
parti fondé par emmanuel macron échec
aux élections municipales et
vraisemblablement aux élections
régionales et pour vous c'est un signe
c'est l'illustration de l'idéologie de
ce mouvement
oui je pense que s'il ya plusieurs
cibles on pourrait analyser pour être
tout à fait honnête on va le faire un
peu rapidement
qu'est ce que ça signifie mais d'abord
effectivement je pense que son échec à
s'enraciner en fait soyons clairs à
avoir des élus locaux
ils n'ont pas seulement des députés
nationaux ou européens
ça prouve que ce parti en fait et bien
le produit de ce qu'on lui reproche de
ce qu'on reprochait meyniel mâcon c'est
d'être un peu un type hors sol un une
sociologie hors-sol mondialisée
déracinés bon ça c'est la première chose
vous souvenez quand cinq ans en 2017
les nombreux thuriféraires de d'emmanuel
macron disait que c'était le comme le
général de gaulle en 58 l'avènement d'un
homme seul et c'est grâce en partie mais
qui à les ancrer mais dès 1959 les
élections municipales donner des tas de
villes ou aux élus qui se réclamait du
gaullisme et du mouvement gaulliste donc
ce que n'a pas réussi à faire emmanuel
macron même dans les métropoles qui sont
les grandes villes où là où la
sociologie et la plus spontanée mon mac
rhône yens vous avez vu que les
maquereaux n'ya n'arrivait pas à déloger
certains élus hidalgo à paris ou alors
moudenc à toulouse ou alors les seuls
qui arrivait à déloger à sortir les
sortants
c'étaient les verts on a bien bordeaux
on a vu à lyon et donc pas du tout le
parti en marche qui reste est une espèce
de bulle de savon désincarné et qui ne
qui ne tenait qu'à son président de chef
est ce que pensait pas aussi que c'est
une rupture dans l'histoire politique
habituellement un parti qui arrivait à
porter son chef aux plus hautes
fonctions de l'état était un parti qui
avait réussi aux élections locales
mais vous avez raison par exemple
l'exemple le plus magnifique c'est
évidemment françois mitterrand avec les
municipales de 77
où il ya une vague rose de ville qui
passe au parti socialiste et qui annonce
effectivement une fois franchies l'échec
des législatives 218 qui est due à
d'autres à la division avec les
communistes mais je repasse pas sur
cette histoire
effectivement qui annonce l'arrivée de
françois mitterrand à l'elysée
pour emmanuel macron ça ne pouvait pas
être ça puisque son parti n'existait pas
en revanche il aurait pu y ont ils
auraient pu s'enraciner ensuite en même
temps pour être tout à fait honnête avec
lui il faut reconnaître que la forme
partisane et peut-être une forme en
train de mourir tous les partis sont à
la ramasse les vieux partis de
gouvernement sont quasiment en état de
mort clinique que ce soit le ps ou à
l'air même le rassemblement national a
vu ses effectifs des militants
s'effondrer il est possible qu'au temps
des réseaux sociaux ou et delà de la
méfiance tombe spontanée vis-à-vis de
toutes les structures là la forme
partisane qu'on soit passé vous avez une
nouvelle forme de démocratie on avait eu
la démocratie des notables sur le
suffrage censitaire en gros 1840 1850
après on a eu les lap les partis
politiques en 1900 jusqu'à années 80 90
et aujourd'hui on aurait les mouvements
avec les réseaux sociaux etc
il sait que c'est possible et avec lié
uniquement à un homme
mélenchon marine le pen emmanuel macron
ça c'est très possible qu'on ait ça et
puis deuxièmement ça a des avantages
macron n'a pas s'embarrasser avec des
militants des grands raouts de grand
raout de militants qui pourraient pester
contre la ligne ou des défauts des
frondeurs envoyé comme le comme françois
hollande a eu donc a des avantages mais
je maintiens que et si vous voulez ça
prouve qu'il est au même niveau qu'en
2010 est c'est à dire un homme seul
soutenue par les grands médias beaucoup
de grands médias avec les réseaux
sociaux ce qui n'est pas rien mais ce
qu'il a fait à françois hollande et plus
généralement à la classe politique
quelqu'un d'autre peut lui faire puisque
il n'a pas envoyé de
2 comment dire de force politique à
l'ancienne merci eric zemmour